By noon the dragon filled the house,
its head hung out the front door,
it's tail hung out the backdoor and
there wasn't a room in the house that
didn't have some part of the dragon in
it.
I bet that there is a house like that on
some of you will live.
You know,
where there's a lot of houses,
some of you live in apartments,
doesn't really matter,
but I bet you if you live in a house on
a block of houses,
there's at least one house on that
street where the tail of the dragon has
started to come out of the house and you
know what that's like it because it's
the house that you don't really want to
look at when you walk by,
you know,
and maybe,
I don't know,
that needs a new roof and like the doors
a little bit crooked and the law isn't
cotton.
You know,
there's some rusty things lying around
there and like it's just not taken care
of.
And you know,
and maybe you know from the gossip in
the neighborhood to that there's
something going on in that house.
It is just not good.
And it's gotten to the point where it's
so not good that it's starting to spread
itself out beyond the domestic confines
of the house.
So you know,
you,
you run into people like that now and
then too,
you'll notice this.
So you know,
sometimes,
I don't know if this has happened to any
of you,
but it might have happened to you in
some ways.
You know that there are those people who
can't not tell you everything about
what's going on in their life,
even if you've hardly even met them.
If you see someone who's really in
trouble,
you know,
you'll sit on the bus and somebody who's
clearly on the road to being thoroughly
de deranged,
we'll sit down beside you and they'll
start telling you about the problems of
their life.
It's like,
you know,
that the dragon that they're dealing
with is so big that they can't even
contain it.
They're so desperate to have it dealt
with that they can't not talk about it.
You know?
And there's lots of people like that.
They're the ones that.
What is that stupid little phrase,
Tmi.
Is that right?
Too much information.
It's like,
yeah,
well why does that happen?
It's because people are dealing with
anomalies and unexpected occurrences and
tragedies and they cannot articulate a
solution and most people think by
talking,
which is also part of the reason that
therapy works.
It's right.
Well,
do you think.
I doubt it.
You might,
but very few people think you know,
and so if you want to solve a problem,
you want to talk it over with a friend
and so you know,
you might just think that you're talking
about the problem sorta you know what
the problem is,
but you're talking about so you don't.
When you talk about it,
you articulate the problem space.
You start to generate potential
hypotheses about solutions,
but more than that,
if you're talking to someone,
you can watch them just like the little
kid with the mouse would watch the
mother.
It's like,
well,
here's what I think the problem is.
And if you go,
you know,
you're listening and you go like that.
You roll your eyes.
You know,
it's a hint to the person that maybe
that's not the most appropriate way to
formulate the problem.
Now maybe you don't roll your eyes,
but you know,
you don't encourage them or maybe they
tell you what the problem is and you
really actively engaged in.
You're nodding.
Well then they know that maybe they
formulated that way,
someone have sane and tolerable would
formulate it and then they can walk
through the solution.
So,
so when you sit down beside someone and
they have to tell you everything,
one of the things that you know is that
they don't have anyone to listen to them
and part of what happens in therapy and
a huge part of it is that you just
listened.
I have one client that's all I ever do
with her.
She comes in twice a week,
once every two weeks and I just sit
there and listen to her for an hour and
now I can maybe have a bit of a
discussion with her for the last 10
minutes.
But if I try to say anything for the
first 50 minutes,
she just looks kinda irritated.
And you know,
it's like I've interrupted the flow of
the,
of the interaction and she's alone.
She didn't have nobody to talk to,
so you know,
she wants to listen to herself,
I think,
and she can't do that by herself.
She has to have someone to do it with.
And so you know,
people think by talking and some people
have no one to talk to and so their
problems start to spill out and you
know,
by that time you can't even help them
usually because if you listened for
three years,
it wouldn't be enough listening.
Just listen forever and you never get to
the bottom of it.